history Moves In One Direction right why
because of time me people people don't
think that a in in what in what way is
and I don't think we've ever like
regressed social standards back to like
oh well let's go a 100 years back and do
things that you know used to exist
before I the entire left right now is
arguing that we regress social standards
by rejecting Row versus Wade so that's
obviously not true the row vers Wade is
not a social standard it's a Supreme
Court ruling number one number two what
if you read the actual majority opinion
on roie Wade we can see that socially we
ever actually never made huge progress
on Society viewed abortion this has
always been an incredibly divisive thing
right even that was I think part of
alito's uh writing on it was that things
like gay marriage for instance we've
kind of moved past and it's not really
as debated anymore but abortion was
never a settled
topic The Arc of History constantly
Moves In One Direction is be lied by
nearly all of the 20th century what do
we mean by that I mean I
mean barbarism communism naism all of
that was a regression from what was
happening at for example the beginning
of the 19th century in the 20th century
what in what way Nazism and communism
wenen a regression from what was going
on in 1905 these are well in terms of
like communism being a regression for
instance I'm not a communist but like
the industrialization of the Soviet
Union happened under a communist Society
the industrialization murder of T of
millions people that a regression a
moral regression which is what we are
talking about now moral regression and
you're you're suggesting that moral
regression I wouldn't term a return to
Traditional Values a moral regression
you would but your suggestion is that
history only Moves In One Direction and
I'm suggesting that history does not
only move in in One Direction it tends
to move actually back and forth sure I
don't think that all of history moves in
one uh One Direction there are going to
be Wars there are going to be times of
peace I think in general we're more
peaceful now than we have been in the
past but I think when we look at the way
that people live their lives I think
that we tend to move in a certain
direction socially so when it comes to
things like racism or when it comes to
things like slavery or women's rights I
think that there are two huge things
that probably aren't changing in the US
and one is access to contraception and
one is women working
jobs
that